la reforma de las pensiones fue
promulgada por el presidente de la
república aparece en el diario oficial
de este sábado para la primera ministra
es el fin del proceso democrático del
texto la oposición no oculta su
decepción esperaba una invalidación de
la Reforma por parte de los sabios del
Consejo pero solo rechazaron dos
disposiciones del texto consideradas
fuera del lugar en una ley
presupuestaria el partido de izquierda
francés sumisa sufre El golpe Pero esto
no significa el fin de la movilización
el hecho de que la ley haya sido juzgada
constitucional no significa que nuestra
oposición a esta reforma de las
pensiones a los 64 años se debilite esto
no cambia el hecho de que seguimos
pensando y Seguiremos pensando y
repitiendo que esta ley es injusta e
inútil en el otro extremo del espectro
político maguen lo penal afirma que el
pueblo siempre tendrá la última palabra
refiriéndose a las próximas elecciones
es de forma una decisión jurídica que
confirma hoy el Abismo que se ha abierto
entre nuestros dirigentes políticos y el
pueblo francés que sigo poniéndose
mayoritariamente a esta reforma de las
pensiones por su parte los sindicatos no
admiten La derrota y convocan nuevas
manifestaciones para el primero de mayo
esperando una movilización masiva
por primera vez desde la posguerra La
intersindical Llama a todos los
asalariados a manifestarse el primero de
mayo para una marea popular histórica
será un maremoto popular inédito festivo
excepcional llamamos a los empleados a
anotar esta fecha
los sindicatos esperan esta vez un
aumento de la movilización tras el
descenso del número de manifestantes en
las últimas semanas